bonjour bonjour à tous donc comme le
disait côtier je suis là pour parler
d'économie alors l'économie c'est la
contraction de deux mots écologie plus
économie ou comment démontrer qu'il est
plus économique de produire de manière
écologique
c'est une méthode certains diront un
modèle qu'on a mis en place dans
l'entreprise pocheco depuis maintenant
vingt ans ça va mettre nos 20 ans cette
année
le point de départ de cette économie
ça a été une crise une crise à la fois
social dans l'entreprise ont parlé à
cette époque-là de harcèlement on
pouvait parler de harcèlement moral des
conflits permanents entre entre les
équipes une perte de cohésion entre les
équipes c'était aussi une crise
écologique
on a retrouvé encore il ya quelques
années des fûts de produits chimiques et
toxiques enterrés un peu partout autour
du site c'était aussi une crise
économique des clients qui portaient les
uns après les autres une mauvaise
gestion financière
tout était réuni pour que l'entreprise
s'arrête et on était là en 1997 tout
pour qu'elle s'arrête où que se
réinvente et la méthode qui a été choisi
à l'époque pour que l'entreprise se
réinventer se reconstruise a été
l'économie l'économie c'est un nom qu'on
a donné à la démarche dans les années
2010 mais c'est vraiment appliquée
depuis 97 alors l'économie c'est le
respect de trois règles chez nous dès
lors qu'on doit investir c'est
dès qu'on investit il faut qu on réduit
notre impact sur l'environnement
première chose deuxième chose il faut
qu'on améliore les conditions de travail
qu'on réduise la pénibilité des postes
et la dangerosité des postes également
et enfin dernier critère nous sommes une
entreprise et nous devons être plus
productifs plus rentables réaliser des
économies l'économie c'est ça c'est
associer les trois critères à chacun de
nos investissements il travaillait pour
pour les atteindre
si je vous illustrer concrètement
l'économie je vais vous expliquer
comment en vingt ans on a réussi à faire
que l'eau de pluie nous sert à nous
chauffer sur le site alors le puits en
plus aujourd'hui ça tombe bien j'ai fait
le constat par vous même que elle est
présente
ce n'est pas moi qui les commande et
pour l'intervention mais le puits c'est
une ressource qui nous tombe dessus
souvent régulièrement et il faut en
profiter et l'utiliser quand on produit
une enveloppe le point de départ ça a
été un travail sur nos encres puisqu'on
a ont produit l'enveloppent pour doit
l'imprimé notre métier est de fabriquer
des enveloppes pour des grands donneurs
d'ordres type des banques des assurances
des opérateurs de téléphonie et jean
pesce donc des enveloppes personnalisées
imprimés quand on imprime donc on
utilise de l'encré
cette encre en 97 et jusque début des
années 2000 était une encre à base de
solvants et de produits chimiques
donc une ancre à la fois nocives pour
l'environnement
de manière générale nocive pour nos
collègues à l'utilisation
quand on imprimé chez nous au départ on
devait porter des gants des masques pour
se protéger de ce produit chimique et
qui en plus était très complexe à
produire puisqu'elle fait il fallait
énormément de produits pour aboutir à
cette encre pour imprimer premier
travail qui a été fait ça a été de
changer la recette de ces encres changer
la recette mais pas nous seuls en
partenariat avec nos fabricants on a
réussi à développer une recette au bout
d'un an de travail avec une encre à base
d'eau et à base de pigments naturels
on a supprimé tout seul ventoux produits
chimiques
jusqu'à supprimer tous les métaux lourds
qui composaient cette cette encre
résultats de ce changement
une encre plus vertueuse moins
polluantes qui nous a permis de
supprimer les masques et les camps dans
l'utilisation et qui nous a également
permis de limiter des locaux dits locaux
à theix atmosphère explosive qui étaient
des locaux hyper protégés et qu'ils
présentaient un danger pour tout le
reste du site
mais c'était aussi l'occasion pour nous
de faire des premières économies
financières puisque en travaillant une
encre à base d'eau et de pigments
naturels
c'était beaucoup plus simple à produire
est beaucoup moins coûteux qu'une encres
à base de produits chimiques
donc c'est là où on a commencé à parler
d'économie ses encres si je reprends le
fils je vous ai parlé et eaux de pluie
qui nous sert à chauffer
on réalise une commande pour un client
ou en fabrique chaque année 2 milliards
200 millions d' enveloppe pour des
dizaines et des dizaines de clients
quand on change de clients on change de
couleur du coup il faut passer par un
nettoyage
le fait de nettoyer aux machines avant
quand nos encres et est à base de
solvants et et chimiques
on devait utiliser des produits type
essence f aussi des produits chimiques
pour procéder au nettoyage le fait
d'être passé sur des encres à base d'eau
on a pu utiliser du savon de marseille
très simple ou en tout cas l'équivalent
ce ce nettoyage donc on utilise du savon
de marseille ou utilisent de l'eau de
l'eau qui est devenu de l'eau de pluie
au fur et à mesure du temps de l'eau de
pluie qui récupère et de notre voiture
donc on a décidé de végétaliser une
grande partie de nos toitures au plus
qui récupère et qui nous servent à
nettoyer nos outils d'impression et
cette eau du coup vient se charger en
encre on parle de à ce moment là de
déchets industriels soulier souliers
mais non polluant puisque je vous disais
on a changé la recette au départ et on a
changé également les produits nettoyants
7 au soulier était auparavant prélevés
dans une citerne qui était rempli une
fois par boire prélevés par un camion
citerne et envoyés à 100 kilomètres de
notre site envoyés à 100 km pour un
traitement industriel un traitement
industriel qui générait beaucoup de
pollution de dégagement de co2 qui
générait aussi un transport jusqu'à 100
km et qui en plus nous coûter 30 mille
euros par an grâce au fait qu on utilise
des encres à base d'eau et puis les
encres à base de solvants on a pu
travailler pour traiter nos eaux sur
place avec une méthode plus naturel et
plus respectueuse de l'environnement et
2 et de l'humain cette méthode ça
s'appelle la phytoremédiation
réalisé par des bombes donc c'est
nettoyer nos eaux souillées grâce au
système racinaire de ce bambou qui en
nettoyant dozos se nourrit de tous ces
déchets qui se trouve à l'intérieur
grandit se développe grâce à ça et du
coup nous a permis d'éviter ce transport
mensuel qui nous coûtait 30 mille euros
par an le résultat si je parle du côté
du côté économique
c'était un d'un investissement de 150
mille euros qui a été fait en 2011 et
une économie de 30 mille euros par an en
cinq ans rentabiliser aujourd'hui on est
en 2010 est la station est toujours là
et se développe de plus en plus ça
devient de plus en plus efficace qu'un
système qui a déjà été amortis chez nous
ces bambous je vous disais je reviens
sur ce que je vous disais au début l'eau
de pluie nous sert à nous chauffer donc
le python sur la toiture est récupérée
dans des cuves sert à nettoyer nos
outils nos cette eau se charge en encre
et devient soulier cette eau du coup
nourrit nos bambou nos bobos grandissent
une fois qu'ils arrivent à maturité on
les coupe on les transforme en pelé et
on se chauffe avec le puits sert à nous
chauffer c'est ça la démonstration de
l'économie dont je vous ai beaucoup
parlé de l'empreinte économique des
systèmes amorti en cinq ans si on parle
de la station d'épuration une baisse de
l'impact sur l'environnement
plus de camions un traitement naturel
par les plantes plus de produits
chimiques puis de solvant est aussi un
risque réduit pour nos collègues par
l'utilisation de ces produits chimiques
mais aussi éviter qu'un camion viennent
une fois par mois sur le site
j'aurais pu aussi vous parler du fait
que tous les papiers qu'on utilise dès
qu'on participe à la découpe d'un arbre
quatre sont replantés systématiquement
dans le respect de la biodiversité des
espèces
j'aurais pu vous parler aussi du fait de
produire de l'énergie renouvelable sur
notre site
j'aurais pu vous parler de la
récupération de chaleur de nos machines
pour chauffer intégralement notre site
est aussi et j'aurais pu vous parler de
la gestion de la mobilité le fait que
nos collègues utilisent des voitures
électriques plutôt que des voitures
thermiques mais ils ne sont pas seuls
dans leur voiture sont plutôt à
plusieurs et que la voiture n'est plus
un billet individuel mais un bien
collectif tout ça toutes ces actions
donc représente l'économie mais
cette méthode de travail c'est aussi
l'humain l'humain au coeur de l'activité
et pour ça je vais repartir de mon
exemple personnel quand je suis arrivé
dans l'entreprise
j'ai réalisé en 2009
j'ai obtenu mon dut en génie mécanique
productique donc orienté pour travailler
dans l'industrie est principalement
mécaniques donc l'automobile le
ferroviaire
à la fin de mon cursus j'ai postulé dans
une école d'ingénieurs pour faire
réaliser un cursus ingénieur par
alternance où j'ai été pris j'ai réussi
mes concours très bien et je devais
trouver une entreprise
j'ai trouvé l'entreprise il est un peu
tard au mois de juillet et j'ai fini
donc 32e avoir trouvé cette entreprise
malheureusement 32e sur 30 qui était
trop tard donc je n'ai pas trouvé
d'entreprise
j'ai dû me réorienter retravailler
trouvé notre voix
cette voie je les trouvais grâce à une
nouvelle licence professionnelle qui
s'était créé la licence professionnelle
éco-conception donc y toucher le milieu
industriel tout en alliant un peu
l'écologie à cette époque là puisque
j'avais des idées des convictions à ce
niveau j'ai intégré cette licence
professionnelle qui venait de se créer
et c'est là où j'ai connu pocheco gelé
connu lors de mon stage de fin d'études
une entreprise qui était à trois
kilomètres de là où j'ai étudié mais que
je ne connaissais pas du tout puisque à
l'époque l'entreprise était méconnu j'ai
entendu quand gauthier présentées que
vous aviez vu le film demain pour une
partie d'entre vous donc du coup vous
avez entendu parler de pocheco
aujourd'hui mais il ya encore sept ans
l'entreprise était vraiment méconnu j'ai
la licence donc elodie ma collègue a
appelé la licence en disant on cherche
un stagiaire j'ai postulé j'ai été pris
j'ai réalisé mon stage en éco-conception
pour réaliser des années d analyse du
cycle de vie avec au départ l'idée de
repartir vers un cursus ingénieur pour
reprendre la filière qui qui me plaisait
au départ et à l'issue de mon stage j'ai
passé quatre mois j'ai été très bien
accueilli et j'ai j'ai vraiment appris
beaucoup et beaucoup grandi pendant
cette période j'ai été reçu quelques
jours avant la fin de mon stage par
yazid
un de mes collègues chez pocheco qui me
disait kevin voilà tu arrives au bout de
ton stage nous on a envie de garder on a
envie de continuer avec toi on voudrait
proposer un cdi la seule chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de poste à
proposer on a envie de continuer avec
toi mais on ne sait pas ou alors il ya
deux solutions soit on continue ensemble
à travailler dans le secteur de la
production où tu as un poste un peu
transversale qui va faire un peu tous
les services et maîtres ton oeil dans la
production essayer de nous faire
progresser en terme d'éco conception on
soit tu travailleras en tant que chargé
de clientèle mais si on veut le garder
c'est qu'on a une idée c'est qu'on
souhaite que l'économie tel qui est mise
en place depuis 97
on développe en tout cas on propose
cette méthode à d'autres entreprises on
voudrait créer un cabinet de conseil et
accompagné de votre entreprise mais
aujourd'hui c'est trop tôt mais on a
quand même envie de travailler avec toi
est-ce que tu acceptes ça et à cette
époque là du coup j'ai accepté j'ai
accepté parce que j'ai j'ai vraiment
passé un moment j'ai apprécié l'équipe
je suis en quelque sorte tomber amoureux
l'entreprise et je me suis dit pourquoi
pas allons-y ils me font confiance je
vais leur faire confiance également là
fiancé quelque chose de très important
dans dans l'entreprise de manière
générale et c'est quelque chose de fort
puisque la confiance passe par le fait
qu' on il ya beaucoup de transparence
transparence dans les chiffres
dans tout ce qui est mis en place dans
tous les projets qui sont montés la
confiance dans le sens aussi où on met
pas des groupes différents sur les mêmes
projets où on travaille plus en
compétition on voit plus créer des pin
hommes d'être in des groupes projets qui
vont avancer dans le même sens la
confiance aussi par le fait que quand on
reçoit quelqu'un en entretien et qu'on
va ensuite l'embauché on lui propose un
cdi directement pas d'emploi cdd pas
d'emploi intéressés le cdi systématique
on a aussi une politique on d'un point
de vie si on parle du côté continue sur
le côté social que l'échelle des
salaires chez pocheco est de 1 à 4 pour
les 130 personnes qui travaillent
aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait tout
le monde est au courant
travailler chez pocheco ne rend pas
riche riche économiquement mais en tout
cas propose autre chose ça passe aussi
par le fait de proposer des services
complémentaires à la vie de l'entreprise
vous êtes embauché pour une tâche vous
êtes embauché par vaux pour votre sapin
votre savoir faire au départ mais aussi
par un savoir être et à dire qu'est ce
qu'on va savoir travailler ensemble
est-ce qu'on va savoir construire
quelque chose ensemble et pour nourrir
ce savoir être complicité cette
complémentarité dans les équipes
on a mis en place beaucoup de choses
comme le sport par exemple où
l'entreprise offre à l'ensemble de
l'équipe
tous les jours des cours de sport en
compagnie par des coachs spécialisés
ça passe aussi par une suivi permanent
du bien-être de l'équipe par des
investissements je vous le disais sur
lancre tout à l'heure où on a réduit
l'impact sur la santé de nous ancre
produits chimiques ont utilisé mais ça
passe aussi par sécuriser les postes de
travail et aussi par un suivi préventif
avec un ostéopathe qui vient une fois
par mois et qui accompagne l'ensemble de
l'équipe dans son dans son bien-être
l'économie ça passe aussi par comment
s'intégrer dans notre environnement
proche donc être à la fois industriel
mais le plus discret possible et ne pas
nuire au village puisque
forest-sur-marque et un est un village
c'est aussi comment aller chercher des
compétences dans le village comme nos
agriculteurs par exemple et travailler
avec eux les soutenir construire des
paniers de fruits et légumes locaux bio
et les proposer à nos collègues en
retour sous forme de d'abonnement et
qu'on a appelé chez nous les paniers de
marianne l'économie c'est tout ça c'est
je vous disais au départ l'eau de pluie
qui nous sert à nous chauffer c'est un
travail en commun un système
hiérarchique aussi retravaillé on va
dire écrasé écrabouillé plutôt que
d'avoir des seins directeur puis un
sous-directeur et ensuite h f
et ensuite l'équipe donc plusieurs
strates hiérarchiques ce qui était le
cas au départ on est revenu sur un
système plus plat où nos responsables
sont des référents des référents qui ont
été tes référent de par leur compétence
leur savoir faire mais aussi leur
capacité à transmettre leur savoir aux
autres personnes à former et à faire
monter en compétences l'ensemble de
l'équipe et les colonies
demain ça doit se partager c'est la
démonstration que j'ai essayé de vous
faire aujourd'hui c'est ce qui a été
appliqué chez pocheco un industriel de
la région
vous avez compris aussi que l' enveloppe
vous savez où on parle on est dans l'ère
de la numérisation des échanges est un
métier en voie de peut-être disparition
même si on va faire pour que ça continue
c'est demain comment continuer nous a
travaillé et comment faire que les pour
que l'économie soit dupliquer soi que
les entreprises s'approprient cette
démarche
eh ben pour ma part dans mon travail
donc je vous disais un peu au début donc
j'ai intégré depuis je suis sorti de la
production d' enveloppe et j'ai intégré
un bureau d'étude bureau d'économie
qu'on appelle chez nous et mon métier
aujourd'hui c'est de proposer aux autres
entreprises industrielles au départ
maintenant entreprises de services mais
aussi des collectivités de mettre en
place les colonies chez elle pas faire
décrocher au copier-coller ce n'est pas
le but est plutôt de raisonner tels que
non un réseau nos départs de tirer le
fil un élément je vous ai cités l'encan
en tirant le fil de l'anc on a réussi à
obtenir que le depuis nous servent à
chauffer
comment
prendre quelque chose en main le
transformer et faire qu'on ait un
meilleur rapport à l'environnement à
notre bien-être au collectif au social
mais aussi à l'économie puisque malgré
un métier qui est en crise pocheco est
encore là pour en parler est encore là
pour pour porter pour témoigner devant
l'économie saisissez vous de cette
démarche profiter et mettez la en place
dans l'entreprise
pour finir si je dois donner une
dernière définition de l'économie c'est
comment entreprendre sans détruire
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]